le temps des vacances c'est aussi pour
certains le temps de se dénuder dans
notre région les naturistes peuvent
exprimer leur passion sur la commune de
puget-théniers parmi eux beaucoup
d'étrangers mais aussi quelques familles
françaises et ce reportage vous prouvera
que l'on peut vivre sans voile et
vénérer le drapeau national jean bernard
vitiello jean crozier qu'est ce que vous
recherchez exactement en venant en
france ici dans les alpes-maritimes et
en faisant du naturalisme l'un tout
d'abord chaud soleil puis le bhoutan
la liberté est ce qu'il ya un côté
réalisation de fantasmes sexuels et
est-ce qu'il ya un côté voyeur dans ce
qui nous fait non non pas du tout
l'érotisme et dans le vêtement un peu
dans la nudité
on sait bien on n'a pas de complexe ça
qu'on soit gros qu'on soit maigre qu'on
106-107 quand vous rencontrer pour la
première fois vous découvrez votre
intimité tout de suite est-ce que c'est
pas gênant si un côté gêne ou pas il est
possible que ça froisse certaines
susceptibilités mai donc je n'ai pas de
rêve formulé en ce sens là chacun est
libre de faire ce qu'il veut enfin vous
êtes habillé là c'est normal
oui vous êtes journaliste vous êtes
habillé aussi je suis dans mon rôle de
travail si par contre je vais à la
piscine tout à l'heure effectivement je
vais adopter la tenue des touristes vous
aimez